O método de diagonalização quântica baseada em amostras, ou SQD para abreviar, é um algoritmo híbrido quântico-clássico como o
Krylov quantum diagonalization KQD, como o VQE e muitos outros. Ao usar tais algoritmos
híbridos, pode ser útil pensar sobre onde cada algoritmo aproveita a computação quântica e a clássica. Lembre-se de que o VQE cria estados em um
circuit quântico usando parâmetros otimizados classicamente. Nesse caso, o estado em si está em um computador quântico. Embora
obter o estado alvo seja um processo que combina tanto a computação clássica quanto a quântica.
O valor esperado do operador é calculado usando medições quânticas.
Mas alguma combinação clássica de termos também é necessária.
Em contraste, o SQD usa um computador quântico para gerar um subespaço útil sobre o qual o Hamiltoniano ou outro operador pode ser
projetado. O Hamiltoniano é então diagonalizado inteiramente de forma clássica para encontrar o estado alvo. Suponha que temos um
problema de interesse para a ciência ou indústria que pode ser formulado como um problema de autovalor numa matriz de n linhas e
n colunas. Suponha ainda que n é grande o suficiente para que a diagonalização clássica exata não seja uma opção.
Claramente seria vantajoso reduzir as dimensões da nossa matriz preservando todas as características relevantes do estado fundamental. De fato, esse é o
objetivo de muitas abordagens aproximadas de autovalor, incluindo os métodos de Krylov clássicos. Vamos supor que sabemos o suficiente sobre nosso problema para fazer uma
suposição razoavelmente boa sobre a forma do estado fundamental, mas não o suficiente para resolver o problema diretamente. Nesse
caso, poderíamos fazer muitas medições da nossa aproximação razoável do estado fundamental alvo. Os resultados dessas
medições nos dão um subespaço de estados de base computacional que contém todos os componentes relevantes do nosso
estado fundamental. Projetar sobre esse subespaço produziria uma matriz menor que ainda contém os graus de liberdade relevantes.
O fluxo de trabalho para isso é o seguinte. Você começa escolhendo um bom ansatz.
Mais precisamente, escolha um ansatz cujo suporte coincida com o do estado alvo. Vamos discutir exatamente o que
isso significa. Em seguida, meça o estado na base computacional, como é feito com o sampler primitivo.
Depois, use os resultados da amostragem para definir um subespaço que contenha o estado fundamental.
Em seguida, projete sua matriz sobre esse subespaço. Por fim, diagonalize a matriz projetada menor de forma clássica.
Vamos detalhar cada uma dessas etapas, prestando atenção especial à definição do subespaço.
Em toda a computação quântica, escolher um bom ansatz é sempre fundamental. No caso do SQD, sua escolha de ansatz
vai determinar quais estados de base computacional podem ser medidos na amostragem.
O verdadeiro estado fundamental pode ser expresso como uma superposição de algum subconjunto de estados de base computacional. Esse subconjunto
é chamado de suporte do estado fundamental. Para obter uma boa estimativa do estado fundamental e de sua energia, seu ansatz
deve ter uma projeção não nula sobre os estados de base computacional no suporte do estado fundamental.
Esse diagrama representa o espaço abrangido por todos os estados possíveis no número de qubits sendo usados. Queremos um
ansatz com suporte que contenha o suporte do verdadeiro estado fundamental.
Considere um exemplo de sistema muito pequeno com um estado fundamental de s_ground = 8 ×
o estado 1 0 0 mais 6 × o estado 001.
Esse tem suporte composto por esses dois vetores 1 0 0 e 0 0 1. Digamos que o ansatz tem a forma ansatz_1 = A vezes
o estado 1 0 0 mais B × o estado 0 1 0 mais C × o estado 001. De modo que seu
suporte é o conjunto de três vetores 1 0 0, 0 1 0 e 0 0 1 — um superconjunto do
suporte do estado fundamental. Esse é um bom ansatz.
Agora imagine que em vez disso tivéssemos escolhido um ansatz da forma ansatz_2 = a ×
o estado 1 1 0 mais b × o estado 011.
Esse tem suporte composto por esses dois vetores 1 1 0 e 0 1 1, que não têm sobreposição com o suporte do estado
fundamental. Esse é um mau ansatz.
Observe que não exigimos necessariamente que o ansatz seja uma boa aproximação do estado fundamental. O ansatz pode
ter suporte muito maior, ou os coeficientes podem ser muito diferentes no ansatz e no verdadeiro estado fundamental, e ainda funcionar bem.
Nesta etapa, usamos um ansatz bem motivado para fazer o computador quântico adotar o estado similar ao nosso estado
alvo. Mostrado aqui está o ansatz UCJ (unitarily coupled Jastrow), que é muito útil em química quântica.
Agora queremos medir o estado do sistema, obtendo strings de bits que descrevem o estado colapsado de cada
qubit. Lembre-se de que a estimação do Hamiltoniano, como no VQE, requer muitas medições quânticas. Isso é em parte para
reduzir a incerteza e em parte por causa do número de grupos de Paulis que comutam que compõem o Hamiltoniano.
Em métodos de amostragem, você ainda precisa de muitas medições, mas os motivos são diferentes. Agora precisamos de muitas medições para amostrar efetivamente os
muitos estados de base computacional envolvidos em estados quânticos altamente entrelaçados. No SQD, as strings de bits amostradas correspondem
a configurações do sistema simulado. Se o sistema estudado está sujeito a restrições absolutas como
leis de conservação em física ou química, então a maioria dos estados medidos serão válidos. Mas algumas strings de bits
amostradas correspondem a configurações inválidas ou não físicas devido a ruído e erros. Um processo chamado
recuperação de configuração visa refinar essas amostras ruidosas em um conjunto de configurações mais precisas.
Esse processo envolve gerar novas configurações invertendo probabilisticamente bits individuais com base em
ocupâncias orbitais médias e números de partículas conhecidos.
As configurações refinadas são então usadas para abranger subespaços para projeção e diagonalização do Hamiltoniano,
melhorando iterativamente a fidelidade da representação do estado quântico.
Vamos ver um exemplo trivialmente pequeno de recuperação de configuração para entender seu significado. Suponha que medimos um
sistema quântico com quatro qubits representando quatro orbitais moleculares e obtemos as seguintes strings de bits do
processador quântico. Cada string de bits representa a ocupação de um orbital: 1 para
ocupado, 0 para desocupado. O Qiskit usa uma notação na qual o qubit menos significativo fica na extremidade direita.
Por exemplo, 1 0 1 0 indica que os orbitais 1 e 3 estão ocupados. Essas
medições foram escolhidas apenas por razões pedagógicas. As ocupações resultantes podem não corresponder a um sistema físico. Em contextos físicos, é
frequentemente o caso de o sistema ter um número total de partículas conhecido. Pode também haver outras leis de conservação que
você pode usar para determinar a fisicalidade de um estado medido. Para ser concreto, vamos supor que nosso sistema é
conhecido por ter um número total de partículas de n = 2. Isso nos diz o número total de uns que devem aparecer em nosso rótulo de estado,
o que é chamado de restrição de peso de Hamming.
No entanto, algumas configurações medidas violam essa restrição. O estado 1 0 1 0 é fisicamente válido. Mas o estado 1 1
1 0 tem partículas demais e o estado de todos os zeros tem partículas de menos —
zero, de fato. Essas violações podem ser devidas a ruído no sistema ou erros de medição. Precisamos de uma forma de retornar
a configurações que façam sentido físico, pelo menos de forma aproximada.
Isso é chamado de recuperação de configuração.
Para corrigir nossas amostras ruidosas, invertemos probabilisticamente bits em configurações inválidas com base na
ocupação orbital média calculada sobre configurações válidas.
As ocupações orbitais são os valores esperados do operador de número agindo em cada orbital. Isso é estimado e
refinado de forma autoconsistente usando os estados produzidos pelo SQD. Vamos olhar para o orbital 2, por exemplo. Em dois dos
quatro estados válidos, o orbital 2 estava ocupado. Isso nos dá uma ocupação esperada de 0,5.
Fazemos o mesmo para os outros três orbitais. Agora voltamos a uma configuração inválida: 1 1 0. Podemos inverter um dos
bits de 1 para 0 para gerar uma configuração válida. Mas qual devemos inverter? Uma forma de decidir é
pela desvio da ocupação de cada orbital em relação às médias que acabamos de calcular.
Aqui vemos que a maior diferença está na ocupação do orbital um. Então poderíamos esperar que o bit um deva ser
invertido de um para zero. Claro, o orbital 2 não está muito atrás. E é sempre possível, por mais improvável que seja, que
esse estado medido seja o resultado de múltiplos erros no mesmo estado.
Escolher apenas o maior desvio da média para todos os estados inválidos não é ótimo. Em vez disso, os bits são invertidos
probabilisticamente, com a probabilidade sendo uma função das diferenças mostradas aqui. Vamos supor que neste
caso realmente mudamos o bit que mais difere da ocupação média. Então 1 1 0 se torna 1 0 0. Faríamos o
mesmo processo para a outra escolha inválida. Digamos que neste caso acabamos invertendo os bits um e três.
Após esse processo de correção, temos um novo conjunto de configurações que pode se parecer com este.
Usando esse conjunto refinado, podemos atualizar a ocupação orbital média para melhorar a fidelidade. No nosso caso, as novas
ocupações são estas.
Esse processo de recuperação iterativa garante que as medições ruidosas sejam filtradas para configurações fisicamente
significativas, melhorando a precisão das aproximações de autoestado no SQD. O add-on do Qiskit para SQD tem algumas ferramentas que
serão fundamentais nesse processo. Se fizemos um bom trabalho amostrando os estados no suporte do verdadeiro estado fundamental
do sistema, devemos ser capazes de olhar apenas para as partes do Hamiltoniano que agem sobre esse subespaço
e ainda obter um bom estado fundamental e energia. No nosso exemplo trivialmente pequeno de 4 qubits, há inicialmente 2^4 ou 16
estados possíveis do sistema. Usando uma combinação de amostragem e recuperação de configuração, reduzimos isso
para três estados em nosso subespaço de interesse — três estados que esperamos compor o suporte do verdadeiro estado fundamental.
Agora projetamos nosso Hamiltoniano completo sobre esse subespaço. Ou seja, fazemos uma matriz M a partir de uma coluna de vetores do nosso
subespaço recuperado amostrado, e uma análoga M† a partir das linhas, e multiplicamos M† HM
pictoricamente. Isso significa pegar os elementos da matriz nas linhas e colunas correspondentes aos estados em nosso
subespaço recuperado amostrado. As linhas e colunas destacadas são as correspondentes ao nosso subespaço. E as
caixas com destaque mais escuro onde elas se sobrepõem são os elementos que mantemos para nossa nova matriz projetada.
Agora que selecionamos o subespaço de interesse, podemos diagonalizar essa matriz em um computador clássico
usando um solver padrão. Se o verdadeiro estado fundamental é composto inteiramente de estados em nosso subespaço, essa
diagonalização deve produzir o estado fundamental correto e a energia do estado fundamental. Se temos apenas a maior parte do suporte do estado fundamental,
podemos nos aproximar. Depois de obter o estado fundamental para esse Hamiltoniano projetado, temos um estado muito
útil a partir do qual calcular a ocupação média de cada orbital.
Anteriormente, nossas ocupações eram calculadas a partir de estados que amostramos usando um ansatz que esperávamos nos ajudar
a nos aproximar do estado fundamental. Mas não havia garantia de que a ocupação média de cada orbital dessa amostragem correspondesse à ocupação
no estado de menor energia. Vamos recapitular. Tínhamos uma amostragem de estados computacionais. Usamos a recuperação de configuração
para corrigir os que eram fisicamente inválidos. Depois calculamos a ocupação orbital média usando todos eles. O
estado fundamental pode incluir apenas alguns deles. O estado fundamental desse Hamiltoniano projetado pode não ser o verdadeiro estado fundamental
do nosso sistema original, mas é o estado de menor energia que pode ser criado usando qualquer superposição dos
estados recuperados em nosso subespaço. A ocupação orbital desse estado vai produzir uma energia menor ou igual à
energia da ocupação obtida do espaço recuperado. Então essa ocupação é uma estimativa melhor da nossa
ocupação do estado fundamental. Podemos repetir o processo de recuperação de configuração usando essa nova ocupação e podemos iterar
isso até que nossos critérios de convergência sejam atendidos. A diagonalização quântica baseada em amostras é rápida comparada a
outros algoritmos de curto prazo como o VQE. É mais escalável e é robusta ao ruído e aos erros na amostragem. Ainda
requer que preparemos um bom ansatz com uma grande projeção sobre o suporte do verdadeiro estado fundamental do nosso sistema. Se nada for conhecido
sobre o nosso verdadeiro estado fundamental, o SQD pode precisar ser usado em conjunto com outros métodos para primeiro aprender sobre o
estado fundamental e se aproximar dele iterativamente.
O SQD desempenha um papel fundamental no conjunto emergente de algoritmos híbridos clássico-quânticos e é um dos
maiores impulsionadores em direção à computação quântica útil.